Maybe you should remind people about what happened.
NOTE CONF
I mean, we should all just go to the Science
Experience Day.
NOTE CONF
That's what that was.
The other thing I was gonna do instead of this
NOTE CONF
lecture.
The OK, help I need some stuff for.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I want to help out Joanne.
But I had to let you.
NOTE CONF
Well, I don't mind that.
Except yeah.
NOTE CONF
Cancel electrical.
Uh, yes, I know there's a 3000 meat shop.
NOTE CONF
I'm trying to graduate to a bit of sketching programme,
but I haven't got the up my ipad game.
NOTE CONF
I heard that.
I have heard that one.
NOTE CONF
I'm trying just this sketchbook at the moment, which I've
also been told is good and it's working for me,
NOTE CONF
but I've got some Still got some learning to do.
Hello?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, this one.
It's got liars.
NOTE CONF
All I really wanted was liars anyway.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Figured I got out my game.
No more of this one note stuff makes me look
NOTE CONF
like an amateur.
OK, so let's see.
NOTE CONF
Are we broadcasting into the ether?
Let's check.
NOTE CONF
See if it goes, OK?
No questions.
NOTE CONF
No complaining.
Probably nobody present, but that's good.
NOTE CONF
All right, We are up to functions part one plus
closure today.
NOTE CONF
But we'll do a quick sidetrack to talk about assignment
stuff, uh, and exam stuff.
NOTE CONF
So the exams are almost There's only a couple of
people left with their supplementary, so they're almost all sorted.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the exam grading for the distinction exams is going
on now.
NOTE CONF
Um, just keep an eye out as they come out.
They won't all come out for everybody all at the
NOTE CONF
same time.
They'll just be available as soon as we've finished marking
NOTE CONF
your set of questions.
But it might take a little while.
NOTE CONF
Uh, we're a bit short on markers at the moment.
We'll make sure that they're back in time for the
NOTE CONF
end of semester exams, though, So that's your warning.
That might take longer than two weeks.
NOTE CONF
Well, it's definitely longer than two weeks because we had
to run all the supplementaries and everything before we could
NOTE CONF
even start marking.
And there were lots of those, so it might even
NOTE CONF
be more than I guess.
It's gotta be pretty much two weeks from now, cos
NOTE CONF
then we're gonna be running the the next round of
the end of semester exams, which will remind, uh, the
NOTE CONF
past parts in Week 13 and then the distinction parts
during the exam period and then the But the next
NOTE CONF
thing you want to be focusing on Oh, and that
second half exam only covers material that wasn't in the
NOTE CONF
first half.
So you don't have to res study that stuff to
NOTE CONF
split.
Um, but what you want to be concentrating on is
NOTE CONF
the next assignment.
I started to get some questions in on that, which
NOTE CONF
is good and a reminder.
The questions are by design.
NOTE CONF
We've been talking since the start about how subtle the
semantics of programming languages are, And so I write down
NOTE CONF
a specification.
That's what's written in the specification thing, and that's enough
NOTE CONF
for us to mark you off.
But, um, more details might appear in forum posts, so
NOTE CONF
keep an eye on those.
Uh, things aren't going to appear on the Forum post
NOTE CONF
the day before that.
All of a sudden, everyone's going to get in their
NOTE CONF
example scripts.
But, um, you get the idea.
NOTE CONF
It's definitely more substantial than the first assignments, and I
try and do it in five minutes.
NOTE CONF
OK, now, again, I don't have the windows example here
because I'm being very careful with the windows example cos
NOTE CONF
that's what everybody managed to mess up last time.
Um, so some notes on the first assignment, this won't
NOTE CONF
apply to any of you.
So there were about 15% of students.
NOTE CONF
So I've been getting this message from the students.
They're like, Oh, I heard that everyone failed like, No,
NOTE CONF
no, only a small percentage failed.
15 of the first assignment.
NOTE CONF
In fact, the same percentage that are probably gonna fail
the course, like 15%.
NOTE CONF
Um, but of those 15% that messed up their zip
file, um, I've been going back and forth with everybody
NOTE CONF
on it and every single person I've spoken to messed
up the zip file, they made a mistake.
NOTE CONF
They didn't read the specs correctly.
They read the specs and just did something different.
NOTE CONF
Um, so, like, I'm not re we're not going back
and remarking people who zipped wrong and just going Oh,
NOTE CONF
well, uh, we'll just mark you normally, but so that
you can learn mostly so that you can learn how
NOTE CONF
to zip for the next time around, cos you've got
to do exactly the same thing for the second assignment
NOTE CONF
to make sure you give you the chance to learn
so that you don't make the same mistake next time.
NOTE CONF
Once you've worked out exactly how to zip your directory
correctly according to the instructions, you can show it to
NOTE CONF
me or to any of the tutors that you're able
to zip.
NOTE CONF
That's what you're showing them, not your code, not how
it works, that you know how to construct the zip
NOTE CONF
file according to the instructions.
Then we'll go back and mark your first submission and
NOTE CONF
with a max of 50%.
So there's 50% penalty for having made that mistake.
NOTE CONF
But you're not getting remarked unless you can demonstrate to
us that you've worked out how to do the zipping
NOTE CONF
correctly.
OK, so that we don't have the same thing happen
NOTE CONF
next time.
So the Post went up about that, Uh, and you've
NOTE CONF
got till the end of this week because we can't
just keep dragging it on forever and ever.
NOTE CONF
So that means you've got this week's class this week's,
uh lecture here today, um, to to get that happening
NOTE CONF
and because I've been going back and forth emailing almost
every single person that had this problem, I've already explained
NOTE CONF
to everybody how the zip should be done.
So you should all know by now.
NOTE CONF
Do we have any questions on that?
Not from you.
NOTE CONF
I'm sure you all did very well.
OK, well, let's get into functions then.
NOTE CONF
So we split functions into two parts.
It's another one of these big, chunky topics and in
NOTE CONF
fact, functions is actually over three weeks because resolving and
binding, which is next week, is really a fix up
NOTE CONF
for something that happens this week.
That's not quite right.
NOTE CONF
Our focus here is all about, um, environments and how
they interact with the traversal of the abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna be doing lots of diagramming again.
What I'm giving you here are example diagrams.
NOTE CONF
You can do it your own way, but I'm likely
to put into exams, um, diagrams that I then ask
NOTE CONF
you, you know, which code corresponds to this diagram, and
that's gonna be in the same style as I do
NOTE CONF
here.
So you wanna make sure you do wanna make sure
NOTE CONF
you understand what I'm drawing up on the screen?
Uh, if something's confusing, you should ask me cos you
NOTE CONF
might get a similar picture in a in an exam.
And the reason we do that instead of doing it
NOTE CONF
the other way is that we're often trying to put
things in these past exams that have got to be
NOTE CONF
auto.
So if I ask you to draw the diagram that
NOTE CONF
relates to this code, first of all, I gotta worry
about what your style of diagram is.
NOTE CONF
And I want you to be free to choose your
own.
NOTE CONF
But secondly, you're gonna mark it by hand because we
do it the other way.
NOTE CONF
I draw a diagram, and then I give you a
multiple choice of what code matches against it.
NOTE CONF
It exercises the same part of your brain.
Uh, well, in fact, exercises it even a little bit
NOTE CONF
better.
And, uh, we can put it in that past exam
NOTE CONF
where you get the multiple attempts.
So that's good.
NOTE CONF
A good way of learning, doing exams multiple times.
So that's one of the reasons I'm focusing on diagrams
NOTE CONF
here today.
But the other reason is that the notes have everything
NOTE CONF
else you need.
Last couple of weeks, I've pretty much been reading out
NOTE CONF
the notes.
You don't really need me to do that.
NOTE CONF
I did that a bit because it was clear to
me people weren't reading the notes themselves.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but too bad.
Now, please, go read the notes yourselves.
NOTE CONF
I think we've the workshops.
Now, Each start of each workshop is make sure your
NOTE CONF
code is up to date, and hopefully you're all doing
that before you get to the workshop.
NOTE CONF
Um, and you'd have to should be reading through the
book to make that happen.
NOTE CONF
So we're getting more into the concepts.
Try to add some value to the book rather than
NOTE CONF
just repeating the book.
Uh, which, of course, is what I told you at
NOTE CONF
the start of semester.
But we adjusted a little bit as, uh, as semester
NOTE CONF
went on.
All right, we are on crafting interpreters.
NOTE CONF
OK, so let's say over three weeks.
Part one.
NOTE CONF
Part two, part three in part one.
We're just dealing with function calls.
NOTE CONF
Well, not just We're mainly dealing with function calls.
Uh, but to exercise that a little bit, we add
NOTE CONF
built in functions, and we show you what a built
in function should look like in a interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Every language you've ever used has built in functions.
The print function is normally a built in function in
NOTE CONF
in locks.
It was done as a keyword as an operation with
NOTE CONF
special syntax.
Uh, but the syntax was exactly for functions.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and then every other thing, like a print, like,
you know, the there's millions of them built in functions
NOTE CONF
in your language, but, uh, they're often squirrelled off into
Well, no, I mean, let's talk about this a little
NOTE CONF
bit, built in functions versus not built in functions.
So if we look at a bit of java code,
NOTE CONF
what are you gonna open up here?
Nothing cool.
NOTE CONF
So if I do my standard to function, there's no
imports here.
NOTE CONF
There's no nothing.
But are there any built in functions being used in
NOTE CONF
this code?
Well, this is where it gets a little bit grey.
NOTE CONF
What counts as a built in function?
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, so print line could count as a built in
function here, but many languages like to at least pretend
NOTE CONF
that the built in function is not really built in.
They like to minimise, built in functions.
NOTE CONF
And so they're pretending that that print line is actually
from a library and that I think in Java I
NOTE CONF
can do in modern Java.
I think I can do that and still get and
NOTE CONF
then run print line.
Um, but in your mind you might be thinking that
NOTE CONF
the print line library or you might be thinking that
the print line function is a method on the out
NOTE CONF
object and the out or the out object.
And that's a field of the system object or something.
NOTE CONF
So that's a way of thinking of it as coming
from a library instead.
NOTE CONF
But even if you think of it that way, always
Java comes with a set of standard libraries that are
NOTE CONF
guaranteed to be there.
They're the ones in system, and so they're built in
NOTE CONF
for all intents and purposes.
But other languages will have a set of just built
NOTE CONF
in functions.
Hasket, which we look at next week, which is one
NOTE CONF
I know has, uh, no re yeah, read and show
and other things.
NOTE CONF
But what we're doing here in locks is we're being
really clear about what built in means.
NOTE CONF
We're not pretending it's in a library, um, or saying
it's a fun, another way to describe built in functions.
NOTE CONF
As you say.
They're a function that's in the run time.
NOTE CONF
Remember, we spoke earlier in this term about how compiled
languages often come with a run time that's doing a
NOTE CONF
lot of the hard work.
So when you compile your programme, it doesn't just compile
NOTE CONF
your programme.
It compiles it in with what we might call the
NOTE CONF
runtime.
Well, the runtime hiding is is where all these built
NOTE CONF
in functions are.
It's being clear.
NOTE CONF
There's just functions built into the interpreter.
They're there.
NOTE CONF
You don't have to define them.
You don't have to import them.
NOTE CONF
You don't have to do anything.
They're just there.
NOTE CONF
So what does that look like in in the design
of our interpreter?
NOTE CONF
Well, I'm jumping ahead a bit, so let's maybe get
back to, uh, just dealing with function calls, which is
NOTE CONF
the first thing we've got to deal with.
So we we've actually already passed this syntax before, the
NOTE CONF
syntax where we've got a name and then parentheses, and
then some parameters and then a semicolon.
NOTE CONF
We did it when we passed the print statement, but
we did it when it was specifically just the word
NOTE CONF
print.
We're gonna need to pass the same kind of thing
NOTE CONF
without knowing exactly what's on that left hand spot.
We also, though, need to allow because functions can return
NOTE CONF
functions in locks.
We need to allow the syntax where the thing on
NOTE CONF
the left is not just an identifier with the function
name.
NOTE CONF
It's some little bit of syntax that eventually gives me
a function as the return value, because then I can
NOTE CONF
pass parentheses into there as well.
So I've got to support this syntax where I can
NOTE CONF
have multiple sets of parentheses running after whatever.
The thing I've found is so the way he chooses
NOTE CONF
to do it, I think, is by calling this function
application or the the application of parentheses to something.
NOTE CONF
He thinks of that like an operator.
But it's supposed to in case you didn't get these
NOTE CONF
words right.
Uh, Infix mi sorry.
NOTE CONF
Infix prefix and postfix, uh, are often applied to operators.
Um, we have one prefix operator in the language so
NOTE CONF
far.
What's that one?
NOTE CONF
We have a single prefix operator in locks already.
It is the exclamation mark or bang for not and
NOTE CONF
we have another one.
We have a second prefix operator.
NOTE CONF
Question mark.
Now we don't have to do that.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the minus for making a number negative, but that's
not really an operator.
NOTE CONF
We can Yeah, OK, so we got those two prefix
operators, so they sit before the thing they're talking about.
NOTE CONF
We've got a heap of infix operators which go between
things, so that's plus minus D equals blah, blah, blah.
NOTE CONF
And now we've got one postfix operator, which is the
parenthesis for passing arguments.
NOTE CONF
But I do want to talk a little bit more
about this way of thinking of function, application or or
NOTE CONF
or passing parameters to the functions cos I don't think
it will be familiar to you all.
NOTE CONF
So I'm just trying to get at some intuition of
what happens in your head when you see a piece
NOTE CONF
of code like and, boy, I have to ask you,
if you had to explain to someone what was going
NOTE CONF
on here, what would your explanation be?
And I'm keen to hear from anyone.
NOTE CONF
You're just trying to be precise about what you're looking
at in any way, shape or form.
NOTE CONF
So someone's walked up to you on the street, flash
this card in front of you.
NOTE CONF
They're doing a they're looking for the next viral video,
but it ain't gonna happen and, like, What's this?
NOTE CONF
Be precise.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So you're calling the grid line function?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
I'll see you in the front.
So one o'clock.
NOTE CONF
Very good.
OK, so that's a good explanation.
NOTE CONF
We're calling the print line function and passing in a
parameter of high.
NOTE CONF
Very good.
That's perfectly correct.
NOTE CONF
And I've just drawn a little, um, line there to
think because I think in your head implicit in that
NOTE CONF
was that the print line and the high are all
just kind of one piece.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, well, here's another way of thinking about it.
Another way of thinking about it is that go find
NOTE CONF
the print line function and send up.
Let me try and get the right language here.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, go find the print line function and send in
a pile of parameters and let her do it at
NOTE CONF
once.
Subtle difference.
NOTE CONF
Right?
Um, and that's a better way to think of it
NOTE CONF
as you get deeper into programming language theory.
Because then the example we saw in the text starts
NOTE CONF
to make some sense because if you have call back
parameter parameter, if I use the first definition, well, let's
NOTE CONF
let's send it a single parameter just for the fun
of it and send it another one there.
NOTE CONF
If using the first way of describing it, I'm saying
I'm finding the callback function and passing at a parameter
NOTE CONF
of one and then I'm what then I'm what?
OK, whereas this other way of thinking of it, I
NOTE CONF
think, makes better sense.
It says, Go get the callback function and send it
NOTE CONF
a parameter of one, and whatever comes back from that,
send it a parameter of two.
NOTE CONF
So this sending of a parameter here and I'm really
just doing this so I can bring out the idea
NOTE CONF
that the sending of a parameter here we will call
well, one way to call it the real name for
NOTE CONF
it is function application to arguments or parameters.
Perna with function application being the keyword, and we tend
NOTE CONF
to think of it as if there's this, and the
symbol for it is often an at symbol.
NOTE CONF
We think of it as there's a little application happening
here when the parentheses get sent off and we can
NOTE CONF
think of it as sending to or passing to or
whatever.
NOTE CONF
But there's actually a function and the parameters they're separate
objects and the parameters get sent to the function and
NOTE CONF
it does its job.
OK, so that's what he's trying to call here.
NOTE CONF
That's what he's trying to talk about here.
He's saying, the thing being called the Callee is the
NOTE CONF
function without the parameters.
It's just a function name.
NOTE CONF
Well, no, it's a bit up a hero or something,
wasn't it?
NOTE CONF
I know, um and then we've gotta pretend this application
operator exists, and it's got to be very high precedent
NOTE CONF
because we used to think of those as a single
thing jammed together, and I'm just separating them.
NOTE CONF
But I want them to never really separate.
I don't want a plus or a divide or something
NOTE CONF
to somehow drag the parentheses across.
So it's the very highest precedent in my language so
NOTE CONF
that they stay jammed right next to each other all
the time.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I'm thinking of it more like an operator
now, and that's what he does.
NOTE CONF
He just says there's a new kind of operator.
There's unary operators.
NOTE CONF
They've got to be higher precedents because, um, they're unary.
But after so they're lower precedents.
NOTE CONF
They they were the previous higher precedents, and now I'm
I'm over low.
NOTE CONF
I'm getting even more higher precedents than that by calling
function calls a new kind of operator.
NOTE CONF
I might call this application if I was using my
terminology from before.
NOTE CONF
And that's when I've got anything on the left, parentheses
and some arguments.
NOTE CONF
Cool, cool.
So we get it all the way down at the
NOTE CONF
highest.
Precedents and arguments, which is the new thing in here,
NOTE CONF
is just an expression take of expression, but that should
be familiar to it should be able to put any
NOTE CONF
expression in arguments, not just numbers or literals or anything.
But there is one awkwardness here that this this way
NOTE CONF
of doing the Parsa means that the thing here on
the left can ultimately be any expression.
NOTE CONF
It's said to be primary here, but remember that, um,
that's because of the way dropdowns work.
NOTE CONF
And so my node in my tree, let's make the
tree note to go with this.
NOTE CONF
OK, so if I'm thinking of it that way, what
kind of tree note am I gonna get?
NOTE CONF
Let's put this in something just a little bit bigger
so that I can, um so that I can make
NOTE CONF
some more sense out of it.
I'll do a couple.
NOTE CONF
I'll do some built different built in functions because it
works a bit better.
NOTE CONF
Let's use math dot random.
We're back in Java land here.
NOTE CONF
Just so I've got a syntax to work with, plus
math.
NOTE CONF
And I'm making up these functions.
They don't really exist.
NOTE CONF
Uh, no brand.
But I'm just trying to give you a familiar notation.
NOTE CONF
So let's say we've got a random function.
If you don't give it any parameters, it'll give you
NOTE CONF
a random between nought and one.
If you do give it some parameters, it'll give you
NOTE CONF
a random between those two numbers.
And so that's my operation.
NOTE CONF
What abstract syntax tree do I want to go with
this?
NOTE CONF
But at the top of the abstract syntax tree, I
want a binary operator for the plus.
NOTE CONF
And then on the left, I'm putting the math dot
Rand, what do I want that to look like?
NOTE CONF
Well, I certainly can't use my unary, and I can't
use my binary and I can't use print.
NOTE CONF
I'm definitely gonna have to make up a new syntax
note for this one, and that's a function call.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna make up a new syntax node called
call.
NOTE CONF
But key is what?
So I know it's gonna go on the right.
NOTE CONF
What's gonna go on the right is a list of
expressions.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, to go in the parentheses.
Um, but in this case, that's an empty list.
NOTE CONF
So I'm just gonna use this notation for an empty
list.
NOTE CONF
And on the right hand side, I'll have another call.
And on this one on the right hand side, I'm
NOTE CONF
gonna get it's a list again, and I'm gonna get
a literal one and a literal 31.
NOTE CONF
000 and a little row 100.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
So that's that's obvious enough.
Well, not maybe not obvious, but it's OK, but what's
NOTE CONF
gonna go on the left?
What's so this I know Wants to be a list
NOTE CONF
a VX PR.
I'm happy with that.
NOTE CONF
When I define my syntax tree.
What should I put on the left?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but what's math?
Not, uh So I'm now building my abstract syntax tree,
NOTE CONF
so I've got to use an abstract syntax tree node.
Which type of node am I gonna use?
NOTE CONF
OK, yeah.
If there's a function type available or one, I should
NOTE CONF
create that.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
So maybe this is a function node.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
OK, so that's what a lot of languages will do.
NOTE CONF
And it will work for any of the languages we're
used to using.
NOTE CONF
But in locks, we can construct functions in other ways,
so that wouldn't work for the example above where we
NOTE CONF
did call back two.
Because the left hand side of this function call is
NOTE CONF
not just the function, is it?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So this would be perfect for Java C most other
languages where you don't have first class functions, but in
NOTE CONF
a better language and most modern languages.
Uh, you can get a function not just by giving
NOTE CONF
the function name.
You can get a function by, Well, what are the
NOTE CONF
different ways we can get a function?
So, in fact, even in Java, there are other ways.
NOTE CONF
So try and think of.
So how to get a function function name?
NOTE CONF
There's another one, which is library name plus function name,
but that's not too bad.
NOTE CONF
What's another way?
I well, we have lambdas in Java, for example, but
NOTE CONF
you end up getting them through.
Let's ignore anonymous functions.
NOTE CONF
For now, there's a couple of others.
Well, there's a key one here, which is methods.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and as an example of one way you can
create a method for an object to call is you
NOTE CONF
could do new thing dot method.
That's valid Java.
NOTE CONF
And so this thing on the left here is definitely
not just a function name.
NOTE CONF
It's an entire calculation.
Well, this part of it, at least, is an entire
NOTE CONF
calculation to get an object and then a method named
Jammed on the Edge.
NOTE CONF
So we're really growing the set of things that can
possibly create the left hand side of one of these
NOTE CONF
function applications.
And once we grow far enough, we realise that the
NOTE CONF
thing we really wanna use is Do you know the
top of our language either a statement or an expression?
NOTE CONF
Uh, which one is appropriate here?
Expression.
NOTE CONF
So, really, the left hand side of a function call
node needs to be a whole expression, OK, and that's
NOTE CONF
what the A SC generator does.
But that creates a big problem that allows us to
NOTE CONF
do a bunch of things that don't make any sense.
Well, you might have seen they make sense in some
NOTE CONF
languages.
Um, it allows me to write one dot foo uh
NOTE CONF
Well, actually, make about for me to do one and
put parentheses on it.
NOTE CONF
It allows me to go Hello and put parentheses on
it.
NOTE CONF
It allows me to do five plus six.
I put parentheses on it, and none of these things
NOTE CONF
make sense.
Now, the parser can happily accept that it's OK for
NOTE CONF
the parser to accept more than the interpreter will allow.
But we are at some point gonna have to restrict
NOTE CONF
these expressions from any expression to expressions that you can
actually put parentheses on thoughts on how to do that.
NOTE CONF
Five.
Well, actually, the first thing to think about is when
NOTE CONF
can we do this?
Uh, hopefully you If I just told you, you can't
NOTE CONF
do it at the pasa.
You'd be like, Yeah, OK, that's fine.
NOTE CONF
You show me plenty of examples that make me think
I can't do it at the plaza if you can't
NOTE CONF
do it.
The poza What's left the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
OK, so all you've got left is the interpreter because
it just goes past the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
And that actually makes sense because what I'm saying when
I say something has to be done at the interpreter
NOTE CONF
in this case is I'm saying I've got to evaluate
this all the way to the bottom before I can
NOTE CONF
tell you if it's a function or not.
Now you and I can see that five plus six
NOTE CONF
is not a function because we can see that it's
11.
NOTE CONF
Um, but what if it was 432?
I don't know what F 32 returns.
NOTE CONF
Maybe it returns the number five because it's really just
addition.
NOTE CONF
Maybe it returns a function because returning functions is possible
in blocks, I don't know.
NOTE CONF
So to get there, I actually do have to evaluate
this to find out.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So when I say find out, What does that mean?
NOTE CONF
We go, I'm I'm zooming out so we can look
at this tree again.
NOTE CONF
When I passed it, I said, You're gonna get an
expression and then the expressions probably got a bunch of
NOTE CONF
other stuff below it.
This triangle says this is a way, my notation of
NOTE CONF
saying there's a whole another tree under there, but I
can't see it yet.
NOTE CONF
I don't really need to know what it is, and
that's the thing that I've got to evaluate before I
NOTE CONF
can tell you whether you're calling something correctly or incorrectly.
I've got to evaluate this whole Foo 32 before I
NOTE CONF
can tell you if this expression is correct, let me
try and make another diagram.
NOTE CONF
So I'll do the F 321 here.
So this one's gonna look like a call to an
NOTE CONF
empty list and the left hand side.
It's actually gonna be another call to left hand side.
NOTE CONF
And in this case, the left hand side is gonna
be an identifier.
NOTE CONF
And the right hand side is going to be a
list with the literal three and the literal to All
NOTE CONF
right, So I've got over here.
This is the part we're worried about.
NOTE CONF
In my Parsa it only knew that this was an
expression, but in reality it was actually and expression.com.
NOTE CONF
So where in object?
On land, that means there's a superclass and a subclass.
NOTE CONF
Maybe if I just check the subclass, that's enough.
It's not because the subclass is still the pas time
NOTE CONF
information, but I'm now going to tell you that F
32 will return Um, a new function.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna use the built in function that he defines,
which is clock OK, so that's the return of F
NOTE CONF
32 by some magic that we'll we could write.
But But that's what it is.
NOTE CONF
Uh, interpretation time.
I'm going to be traversing this tree.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna first come to the call.
We haven't met the interpreter yet, but I'm pretty sure
NOTE CONF
we're gonna do what we always do.
We just come to the node, interpret the left, interpret
NOTE CONF
the right.
When I interpret the left the interpretation of call ident
NOTE CONF
literal three should give me back Whoops.
Ah, no, it's Oh, that's where I made a mistake.
NOTE CONF
Uh, Fu returns the clock function.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Not a call to the clock function.
Um, So the result of running Foo is going to
NOTE CONF
be maybe one of these function objects, but that doesn't
appear until and part way through the evaluation of the
NOTE CONF
entire thing.
But I evaluate this part and it gets itself down
NOTE CONF
to this clock call and I go cool.
That's what it is.
NOTE CONF
And whenever we do a tree walk interpreter, the tree
walk interpreter is actually just going from the bottom if
NOTE CONF
you trace it through which you should do, please from
the bottom taking out sub tree and replacing them with
NOTE CONF
smaller sub tree and then sub trees, smaller sub trees
until we get all the way down to just one
NOTE CONF
thing at the top and that's what we return.
So now at this point, I've got a call with
NOTE CONF
a function on the left and an empty and I'm
like, Oh, that looks cool.
NOTE CONF
I can do that.
But again, function is gonna be what is a subtype?
NOTE CONF
So it's a combination of what subtype do I get
after evaluating the callee is the question.
NOTE CONF
I'm actually asking to find out if I've done it
correctly or not.
NOTE CONF
If the subtype I got was something that works like
a function good, if the subtype I got was a
NOTE CONF
literal bad.
Now next step, we need to separate out some of
NOTE CONF
the subtypes from the other subtypes.
OK, and the way we do that is with in
NOTE CONF
Java land is with an interface.
So we're making up a new interface here called locks
NOTE CONF
callable and some of our subtypes inherit from it and
other ones do not.
NOTE CONF
And then if we end up with one of them,
that does inherit does implement that in interface, we're OK
NOTE CONF
and if we end up with one that doesn't we're
not OK, all right, So now now we've created, ultimately
NOTE CONF
some new type of node, which is actually a subtype
of locks callable and anything we make.
NOTE CONF
That's a subtype of locks.
Callable can happily sit on the left hand side of
NOTE CONF
one of these function calls.
We won't know until runtime, So at pastime we just
NOTE CONF
grab it as an expression, chuck it in the tree,
and then we rely on the interpreter as it goes
NOTE CONF
through it.
Once it's evaluated that it'll probably have to check it
NOTE CONF
to see if it's a locks callable.
And if it is, it'll go ahead and call the
NOTE CONF
function.
And if it's not, it'll give me a runtime error
NOTE CONF
saying You can't call you.
There's no function called one.
NOTE CONF
All right, cool.
Very cool.
NOTE CONF
So now we're looking at how that's implemented.
So all of that was to explain why we've got
NOTE CONF
expression Corley on the left.
OK, um, it does actually grab the parenthesis for whatever
NOTE CONF
reason.
I don't 100% know why and put that into the
NOTE CONF
the node as well.
So I had a third in in all my nodes
NOTE CONF
that I wasn't doing and then standard Parsa stuff to
put that in.
NOTE CONF
He does it in two parts because there's something he
has to do later in the Parsa.
NOTE CONF
Um, but that's not necessarily actually in this part of
the Parsa, but anyway, it's split into two parts where
NOTE CONF
he first grabs the left hand side, and then he
grabs the start of the arguments.
NOTE CONF
And then he grabs all of the arguments and then
finishes and ultimately gives back, um, one of these new
NOTE CONF
S, uh, a ST nodes, which has got the left
hand side, which is an expression of par end, which
NOTE CONF
we don't care about.
It just sat there and a list of arguments.
NOTE CONF
Uh, at this point, he makes the, uh says I'm
gonna put maximum argument counts in because they're sensible.
NOTE CONF
Uh, he sets it at 255 so you can't call
a function with more than 255 arguments.
NOTE CONF
Sure, I don't I reading through this.
I can't think of a reason locks needs that.
NOTE CONF
I think he's just taking the opportunity here to say,
Well, here's another part of the interpreter You didn't think
NOTE CONF
about before that I can be precise about how many
arguments can you send to a function?
NOTE CONF
And exactly where does that get enforced?
Well, it gets enforced at the pas time, and you
NOTE CONF
gotta pick a number.
And then it gives a little bit of, uh, the
NOTE CONF
the the history of other languages, where in C you've
got to accept at least 100 and 27 arguments, but
NOTE CONF
it's not defined what your maximum is.
So if, um, if you were writing C and you
NOTE CONF
wanted to write a function with 100 and 28 arguments,
you would know for sure that that was gonna work.
NOTE CONF
But if you wanted to write one with 500 arguments,
it's up to the compiler because of the way the
NOTE CONF
seas spec application is written.
We learned partly because of C, that specifications should be
NOTE CONF
written more precisely.
So.
NOTE CONF
Other languages now would normally tell you the maximum number
of arguments, not the minimum number of arguments.
NOTE CONF
Um and so in Java, it says it will accept
any number of arguments between zero and 255 and then
NOTE CONF
no more.
So if you've got a Java compiler that you put
NOTE CONF
in 500 arguments.
It's a not correct Java compiler, OK, but he puts
NOTE CONF
one in.
And as I say, it's a good example of the
NOTE CONF
one that has to be at the PAS phase cos
that's when you can see how many.
NOTE CONF
Well, sorry the earlier You do it the better and
you can do it at the pas phase.
NOTE CONF
So you should.
Alright, so now we go to visiting the call expression.
NOTE CONF
And as I said, visiting the call expression probably means
evaluating the left hand side, evaluating each of the arguments
NOTE CONF
which he does, and then they'll evaluate down to something.
He adds them to this new list he's keeping track
NOTE CONF
of called arguments.
And then the last thing he does is cast whatever
NOTE CONF
the left hand side was into this locks callable, we
just made up, and that obviously is gonna fail.
NOTE CONF
If the cast isn't possible.
It fails if it doesn't implement that interface.
NOTE CONF
So this is like the if statement that says if
you implement that interface, move ahead.
NOTE CONF
If you don't throw a runtime error, so we're gonna
have to go and make sure everything we want to
NOTE CONF
put on the left hand side implements locks callable, and
we're gonna have to define locks callable and everything else.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So what he chooses to do is instead of just
NOTE CONF
saying, if you implement locks callable, which is like my
little signal my flag that you belong on the left
NOTE CONF
hand side.
Then the interpreter goes ahead and keeps doing things.
NOTE CONF
He says if you implement locks callable, I'm gonna hand
off this job to the locks.
NOTE CONF
Callable that you are, you know how to call yourself.
So over there, lox caller's got a call method.
NOTE CONF
Just do it.
And so we're now out of the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Well, we're kind of part.
This locks callable, becomes part of the interpreter because the
NOTE CONF
calling job is done in there, and we allow the
callable to define what the call operator means and the
NOTE CONF
callable knows Well, I'm a callable.
You're about to give me a bunch of arguments.
NOTE CONF
I'll do what I want with them.
Yeah, cool.
NOTE CONF
So that allows us to build basically anything that gives
us complete freedom on what's gonna sit on the left
NOTE CONF
hand side of parentheses and what's gonna sit on the
right hand side obviously this fun in this chapter we're
NOTE CONF
doing functions are sitting on the left hand side of
the parentheses.
NOTE CONF
So how will they work?
Um, but you don't get a function until you define
NOTE CONF
a function, and we're holding that off till next week.
How are we gonna get functions without defining functions?
NOTE CONF
Well, we'll make built in ones.
We'll just have a bunch of functions.
NOTE CONF
Or, in this case, just one just floating around the
interpreter ready to go.
NOTE CONF
It's some object.
It implements the callable, and when you call it, it
NOTE CONF
does its job and the interpreter knows about it.
So it's there.
NOTE CONF
So that's what we do.
Uh, first, the locked callable gets made locked, callable, just
NOTE CONF
has Well, has one argument there.
So I had one, F method called call.
NOTE CONF
It ends up getting given the interpreter for reasons, but
really, the thing it wants is that list of arguments
NOTE CONF
you've al and those arguments have already been computed down
to as far as they can go, right?
NOTE CONF
So that's why it's a list of objects, not a
list of expressions.
NOTE CONF
I wanna actually that's a good thing to point out
that we might have lost track of I'm gonna make
NOTE CONF
another tree.
What?
NOTE CONF
I wanna show you exactly what an interpreter does.
So I'm gonna do the interpreter again, for I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
make the A ST for a another simple function.
Another simple piece of code.
NOTE CONF
Let's just do, um one plus two doesn't have to
be that complicated.
NOTE CONF
We'll just do one plus two plus three.
So when I create the a ST for this piece
NOTE CONF
of, uh, locks, this locks expression, I get binary.
And on the left, I get another binary.
NOTE CONF
And on the left, I get a literal one that
are all to through right, Something you might not have
NOTE CONF
realised but is entirely clear if we noticed.
Uh, this is an abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
The nodes in the tree are expression dot binary.
That's what I've written here.
NOTE CONF
Really.
I mean, I'm not saying anything new, but those are
NOTE CONF
the That's the type the class that it's built from,
and but this is a tree of expressions.
NOTE CONF
So everything in that tree is an expression.
What happens as I evaluate it, I'm gonna put the
NOTE CONF
evaluation in next to it in another colour, and we'll
see if we can trace this and this is a
NOTE CONF
perfect reason why I never give these slides out, because
this will make no sense.
NOTE CONF
When you see the final answer, it'll only make sense
if you follow it along.
NOTE CONF
Well, the interpreter, whether we remember or not, the interpreter
comes to a binary and it says, Um, OK, I'm
NOTE CONF
in a binary.
I wanna evaluate my left and evaluate my right.
NOTE CONF
That's what it means, but once.
So how can I put it?
NOTE CONF
What's the result of evaluating the left and the right?
What?
NOTE CONF
What's the result of the tree visitor?
What's the result?
NOTE CONF
Type of the interpreter, Visitor capital, O object.
So evaluate.
NOTE CONF
And it's true up here as well.
When I evaluate binary, I'm gonna get back an object.
NOTE CONF
When I evaluate the left hand side, I'm gonna get
back an object.
NOTE CONF
When I evaluate the right hand side, I'm gonna get
back an object.
NOTE CONF
So now I go down here and I do the
same thing.
NOTE CONF
You know, evaluate binary.
When I evaluate its left hand side, I'm gonna get
NOTE CONF
an object.
When I evaluate this right hand side, I'm going to
NOTE CONF
get an object and then finally so I'm evaluating the
left hand side first.
NOTE CONF
Alright, When I evaluate the literal to get back the
object, I get back the object one.
NOTE CONF
And so I've converted an expression to an object.
That's what evaluation does.
NOTE CONF
And this part of the trees gone.
Just the number one sits there instead.
NOTE CONF
And then I evaluate the right hand side and I
get two and that part of the trees disappeared.
NOTE CONF
And then I evaluate the binary which in this case
was a plus.
NOTE CONF
And I get the object one plus two, which is
three.
NOTE CONF
And now that whole trees gone.
Now, over here I replace that with a three and
NOTE CONF
this part of the tree goes and then I replace
the three plus three with a six oops, six up
NOTE CONF
there and the rest of the tree goes.
So one way to look at it is that you
NOTE CONF
start with the big blue tree and from the bottom
up, you just start knocking out blue nodes and putting
NOTE CONF
in black nodes.
And then you knock out the blue note and put
NOTE CONF
in the black node and every time And because black
nodes are objects, they shrink when they get to the
NOTE CONF
binary one.
It looks at its two Children, and they throws them
NOTE CONF
away and puts back the number three.
I am at the edge of my abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
I'm turning things into objects and then knocking them all
out as they go up.
NOTE CONF
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I can't remember why I started on that, but it's
NOTE CONF
important.
So Ah, this is why it's not on it all
NOTE CONF
right?
Because by the time we get to the call, the
NOTE CONF
Children of the call node are now black.
They're objects.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, so that's why you see arguments over here.
They're already evaluated, and that's the reason I went on.
NOTE CONF
That sidetrack is that as we're reading an interpreter or
working inside interpreter and we see lists of objects, we
NOTE CONF
see things that have already been interpreted, and we see
lists of expressions.
NOTE CONF
We see things that haven't been, and we think of
the interpreter as just translating expressions into objects and expressions
NOTE CONF
of big trees and objects are just blow.
So it's converting three into a single thing.
NOTE CONF
Three.
Now, if that was all we had in our callable
NOTE CONF
object, we would, um, fail to be able to check
on argument errors, the number of arguments.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I'd just be calling it passing in arguments and
the call would go.
NOTE CONF
Oh, I've got too many.
I don't know what to do or I don't have
NOTE CONF
enough.
I don't know what to do.
NOTE CONF
Um, to help us put better error checking in.
Um, well, so the first thing he's done is he's
NOTE CONF
added this to the interpreter Instead of just casting, he
first checks to see if it's an instance of before
NOTE CONF
he tries to cast.
And that's nice.
NOTE CONF
But that's the If we were talking about the whole
time and then also, every function should know how many
NOTE CONF
arguments it's supposed to take and every function.
Now we're We're capturing everything about a function in this
NOTE CONF
locks callable.
So Locks Callable is gonna have to have a method
NOTE CONF
for the number of arguments that I have.
So it does.
NOTE CONF
So that's a method that just tells me how many
arguments does this callable thing have?
NOTE CONF
How many arguments does this function have?
And finally, we can just define our own function, so
NOTE CONF
what he does is instead of starting with an empty
environment, he makes up an environment full of global.
NOTE CONF
These are things that are built into the language.
Now there's no variables built into the language, so he
NOTE CONF
doesn't put any in there.
Well, you can imagine a language might have variables built
NOTE CONF
in.
I would be with it.
NOTE CONF
But could you think of languages that are very was
built in itself, but, like, I guess Math library.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So perhaps that that's true.
NOTE CONF
That's a good one.
Example was maths libraries, which have constant built in one
NOTE CONF
language I know of that does have variables built in
is bash or pearl The languages we do scripting with.
NOTE CONF
They have dollar $0.01 dollar, $2.03 dollar, $4.05.
They're variables that are built into the language, and, uh,
NOTE CONF
they always get a certain value based on how the
function was called.
NOTE CONF
But we're gonna put functions in an environment.
Um, so the function name is gonna map.
NOTE CONF
So what?
What do we have in the environments?
NOTE CONF
We had variables mapping to expressions, objects.
What were they mapping to objects?
NOTE CONF
They had to be objects because it's got to be
one of the runtime things.
NOTE CONF
So there were variables mapping to objects.
Uh, which means we can put anything we want in
NOTE CONF
there.
So what are we gonna put?
NOTE CONF
Well, we could make the name of the function map
to the callable.
NOTE CONF
That's what That's exactly what he does.
He says, OK, the environment doesn't just co co contain
NOTE CONF
objects now.
It contains objects.
NOTE CONF
Well, it doesn't just contain objects you are thinking of,
like the number one or the string high.
NOTE CONF
It can also can hold cables in the environment and
that that automatically works because objects, anything can be an
NOTE CONF
object.
And so he does that.
NOTE CONF
He says, I'm gonna put into this environment under the
name clock, one of these callable and I'm gonna use
NOTE CONF
the cool, anonymous inner class thing of Java so that
instead of having to say, make a class called clock
NOTE CONF
class that implements the callable and put it in a
separate file, I'm just It's just an inner class anonymous
NOTE CONF
inner class.
It in it extends locks callable.
NOTE CONF
Here's it overriding each of the methods.
And we're done when you it's got a narrative of
NOTE CONF
zero.
And when you call it, it doesn't care what arguments
NOTE CONF
you gave it.
Hopefully you gave it zero.
NOTE CONF
It just gets back the current time from the system
and sends it to you.
NOTE CONF
All right, that's pretty cool.
OK, so this this hits at another topic that the
NOTE CONF
book doesn't explicitly talk about, but I think is very
useful in understanding what's going on in, um, a programming
NOTE CONF
language.
And that is the subset of expressions that count as
NOTE CONF
values.
So I'm going to go back to this.
NOTE CONF
So in this diagram, we were converting expressions into objects
and we were going from blue to black.
NOTE CONF
And there was a one and a two and a
three and a three and a six.
NOTE CONF
So we know for sure that we might see integers
in that slot.
NOTE CONF
But can you imagine if you're imagining other programmes?
What other kinds of things might appear as black objects
NOTE CONF
during the evaluation?
I mean, in fact, in this language, it's doubles.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Let me change that to doubles.
NOTE CONF
What else?
Times?
NOTE CONF
Yep, Exactly the standardised, brilliant string.
But in fact, in locks just double and string.
NOTE CONF
Uh, do we have bulls?
Yeah, we do.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So bullions there as well, right?
NOTE CONF
And we saw one more as well.
Didn't we see void the capital V void was one
NOTE CONF
that came out when we did statements.
Uh, well, these are all concepts in locks that sit
NOTE CONF
under expressions.
Um, but there are other things that sit under expressions
NOTE CONF
that aren't in there like binary operators and a bunch
of other things.
NOTE CONF
As programming language people, we will call this set of
things the values.
NOTE CONF
OK, so values are always a subset of expressions.
They are the smaller set of things that expressions will
NOTE CONF
evaluate to, and they represent things we cannot evaluate any
further.
NOTE CONF
And finally they are exactly the things that go in
the environment.
NOTE CONF
So we were actually capital O.
Object is what we were using on the Java side
NOTE CONF
of things so that we could represent all the different
values that might appear right.
NOTE CONF
But in reality, environment is storing names to values, names
to values.
NOTE CONF
If you ever see a name to a binary in
an environment, something's gone wrong.
NOTE CONF
Because a binary is something that could have been evaluated
further down to something, so it shouldn't be in the
NOTE CONF
environment.
What do we just add to the environment?
NOTE CONF
We just added un evaluated functions.
We just added these callable things And so we're adding
NOTE CONF
to this list.
And it's a piece of interesting programming language theory that
NOTE CONF
functions ready to be called but not yet called are
values in the same way as numbers and strings.
NOTE CONF
You can't evaluate them any further until you get more
information, right Until you get the parameters passed into them.
NOTE CONF
You can't evaluate them any further.
I just thought that was an interesting aside, but something
NOTE CONF
that I wanted to be precise about cos it can
confuse people if you're getting deep into it.
NOTE CONF
Um, yes.
Callable are correctly values.
NOTE CONF
And, uh, the terminology here is quite There's lots of
terminology we might use for these, so I could call
NOTE CONF
them function name.
Right.
NOTE CONF
So it's not the function with the parameters attached.
It's just the name of the function.
NOTE CONF
Um, I could call it an uninterpreted function or an
unapplied function.
NOTE CONF
Um, but here they're just calling it a callable I
something waiting for arguments.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
Right.
NOTE CONF
As a little preview, guess what?
Guess what you're gonna create when you see a function
NOTE CONF
definition.
When you interpret a function definition, what should be the
NOTE CONF
outcome?
Colorable.
NOTE CONF
Exactly.
Um, I'll just show you what I mean, cos interpreters
NOTE CONF
have to go.
This is for next week, right?
NOTE CONF
But interpreters go top to bottom.
Everyone who's been giving me answers that didn't come from
NOTE CONF
their generative A.
I explained the difference between an explanation and, uh oh,
NOTE CONF
sorry.
An interpreter and a compiler by saying the interpreter has
NOTE CONF
to go line by line and make a judgement about
what each thing is worth.
NOTE CONF
So when my when my programme looks like this No,
not deaf.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, Deaf.
Oh, no fun.
NOTE CONF
It's fun in this language, isn't it?
OK, it has to make.
NOTE CONF
As the interpreter goes down, it has to do something
for every line.
NOTE CONF
So for this line, it prints to the screen.
So for this line, it calculates one plus two and
NOTE CONF
gets the answer three.
What does it do for this?
NOTE CONF
That's a single statement.
What does it do for that?
NOTE CONF
This is a function waiting for its arguments.
This is an uninterpreted function.
NOTE CONF
This is an unapplied function.
So that's the locks callable, ready to roll.
NOTE CONF
We've actually built the structure that we're gonna need when
we get to function definitions that we didn't have before.
NOTE CONF
OK, so he's done the built in function called clock,
and that's it.
NOTE CONF
We stop here because that's enough concepts as hopefully you
agree.
NOTE CONF
And then next week we'll look at when we're defining
our own functions.
NOTE CONF
Uh, how do we get into it now?
For this week in the workshop?
NOTE CONF
I believe I've given you questions to help you get
at the life of functions.
NOTE CONF
Let's just remind ourselves of what's in here.
How do we get five attempts already?
NOTE CONF
Um what?
Oh, that's got clock in it.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, So make sure make sure your interpreter is up
to date, so I can.
NOTE CONF
I'm looking at it going well, there's loops in there.
That was last week's.
NOTE CONF
So here is a function that's here's a bunch of
functions that are returning other functions, and it's a convoluted,
NOTE CONF
pointless programme.
But you can only trace it if you've got those
NOTE CONF
concepts in your head that we talked about today correctly.
You've gotta be thinking of functions as potentially uninterpreted things
NOTE CONF
that can be returned and then hang around waiting until
they get parameters applied to them.
NOTE CONF
And so trace this with lots of scribbles on a
piece of paper like I would have done in a
NOTE CONF
lecture to prove that you've got that concept in your
head.
NOTE CONF
And if you can't trace that and your trace doesn't
make any sense, then you haven't understood the idea of
NOTE CONF
a function waiting to be applied.
Um, and then I like this example.
NOTE CONF
And this hint tells you I might use it in
exams as well.
NOTE CONF
So this is your chance to, uh this is a
complicated example.
NOTE CONF
Where if I gave it to an exam, you'd be
like, Oh, man, I need half an hour to get
NOTE CONF
my head around this before you can even ask me
a question.
NOTE CONF
So guess what?
I've given it to you.
NOTE CONF
Now get your head around it and you'll be able
to do it quickly in an exam.
NOTE CONF
And the students who get that question in an exam
and go Oh, my God, that was way too long
NOTE CONF
for an exam.
Are exactly the students who didn't go to the workshop.
NOTE CONF
Um, so, uh, this is a chance to exercise those
same ideas notice here that we we're not really Oh,
NOTE CONF
no, we are adding another the OK, cool.
We're adding another built in function.
NOTE CONF
That's relatively quick.
The hard stuff I think the conceptually hard stuff is
NOTE CONF
getting your head around the way all these, um uninterpreted
functions are acting Who and maybe you can appreciate why
NOTE CONF
locks includes these first class uninterpreted functions or inner functions
or whatever.
NOTE CONF
It's because deep in the compile of machinery, we need
them anyway, cos they're just fun.
NOTE CONF
That's what a function definition turns into.
So it's exposed it at the level of locks so
NOTE CONF
we could start thinking about it at the source level.
But it's a concept underlying that we have to get
NOTE CONF
our head around.
Otherwise we wouldn't be able to define our own functions
NOTE CONF
anyway.
Questions, questions.
NOTE CONF
It feels like a dense hour, doesn't it?
But I'm not gonna just keep saying more things.
NOTE CONF
But there was a lot in that hour.
Hm.
NOTE CONF
Practising.
Is there a particular kind of what we feel is
NOTE CONF
the trace is the The question is, is there a
best way to trace The best way is whatever your
NOTE CONF
brain does The key.
The key to this kind of tracing, um, is that
NOTE CONF
the act of drawing It helps you understand it.
You might do five traces before you finally understand it.
NOTE CONF
Each trace might give you access to a little bit
more of what's going on, and then you might go
NOTE CONF
back and redo your trace for the way you've done
it.
NOTE CONF
And the trace is not the goal.
I'm asking you to create one so you've got something
NOTE CONF
to submit, so you've got a target to aim for.
But the goal is what the trace puts into your
NOTE CONF
head about the way that code is operating.
Um, and as humans, we just I mean, those of
NOTE CONF
you who are doing some kind of maths degree will
understand that mathematicians don't they think in terms of white
NOTE CONF
boards, right?
The maths is entirely abstract.
NOTE CONF
Theoretically, it's entirely abstract, but in practise, it's on the
freaking board.
NOTE CONF
Maths is always written out doesn't exist until it's written
out, because you can't conceptualise it till it's written out.
NOTE CONF
It's the same kind of thing here.
The concepts don't think they can be understood until they've
NOTE CONF
been written out.
And what happens is there's humans who kind of spatially
NOTE CONF
organise things is that the the diagram we've created becomes
a mirror of our internal understanding.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and so that's what it's there for.
It's not the goal.
NOTE CONF
It's the it's the the path to the understanding, and
so do multiple of them and don't stress about whether
NOTE CONF
they're nice or not.
When you're looking at it going, Oh, now I get
NOTE CONF
it.
You're like, Oh, that means you've got a good diagram
NOTE CONF
and there's not And I mean here's an example of
a good diagram.
NOTE CONF
That's a horrible diagram.
But it's a good diagram, right?
NOTE CONF
Oh, sorry.
I'm not protecting, um, this.
NOTE CONF
That's a horrible diagram, but it's a good diagram when
you finish it.
NOTE CONF
It's horrible.
OK, so the end result can look like that.
NOTE CONF
But if it's given you an insight into what's going
on, then that's fine.
NOTE CONF
Now, when I give you diagrams in the exams, for
example, I'm gonna be sticking to fairly simple things, like
NOTE CONF
just a a bland a ST with maybe a bit
of annotation around it.
NOTE CONF
I'm not giving you something like this and asking you
to retrace my evaluation.
NOTE CONF
I maybe giving you some environment diagrams where I show
you a tree of environment or it's a cactus of
NOTE CONF
environments.
Isn't it a cactus of environments, um, and asking you
NOTE CONF
which code might have generated those?
Um But in terms of helping you understand the concepts
NOTE CONF
of what's going on, then I'm giving you these dynamic
diagrams that really only exist as as, um, animations.
NOTE CONF
And you should all appreciate that because most of you
learned your maths from three blue and Brown right?
NOTE CONF
And that's exactly what he brings to the table that
makes it so powerful is that the used to have
NOTE CONF
to go to a maths lecture to see a mathematical
concept evolving on the board and the best maths lecturers
NOTE CONF
were the ones who gave the best videos on the
on the white board or the blackboard.
NOTE CONF
They were drawing one frame and rubbing it out and
drawing the next frame and rubbing it out and drawing
NOTE CONF
the next frame and talking you through it.
And YouTube means that mathematics educators can now do that
NOTE CONF
online.
And so that's what three blue and brand.
NOTE CONF
It creates the animation, and it's a smoother animation, you
know.
NOTE CONF
No in between, you know, just turning up to a
lecture to see it, Um, but it's the thing that
NOTE CONF
makes you understand the concept, but it's the same in
computing is just not as widely accepted or used as
NOTE CONF
well.
And the systems that we're operating with are bigger and
NOTE CONF
more complex, and so animating them gets harder.
Um, but it Yeah, So you're doing that yourself you're
NOTE CONF
under You're animating and understanding little parts of it.
And then that's creating an intuition that you can blow
NOTE CONF
up into a an understanding of the entire system.
OK, any other questions?
NOTE CONF
I put my book ah, closer with AJ.
I keep writing it with an S.
NOTE CONF
So if you see me write it with an S,
it should be AJ and just what I'm doing this.
NOTE CONF
So this is a simple concept.
There's one simple concept, really this week, which is the
NOTE CONF
uninterpreted function, which some of you probably already kind of
understood anyway.
NOTE CONF
But it's like it's hugely important.
Um, and it's actually one of those concepts that you
NOTE CONF
learn in a course like this that gives you a
big leg up in the world of programming.
NOTE CONF
Um, it it how can I put it?
It allows you to roam much more widely than your
NOTE CONF
peers to have the concept of uninterpreted functions in your
head.
NOTE CONF
It's another way for you to think of lambdas when
we taught Lambda in second year.
NOTE CONF
We had to teach it as an object with a
single method called call.
NOTE CONF
Was that what it was called or something?
No, the method cha name changed every time.
NOTE CONF
Um, but now you can have a different conception that
will travel across to other languages in particular languages like
NOTE CONF
clutter.
And I'm wondering if I've got closure here.
NOTE CONF
You should have it.
Yeah, all right.
NOTE CONF
There's my here's my little cloar repel.
So you've probably noticed that most of these languages have
NOTE CONF
repel cos repel are great And the fact that Java
doesn't have a reel is one of its problems.
NOTE CONF
Although there are java repels available now and, uh, more
modern versions.
NOTE CONF
OK, but we're ready to roll with C.
OK, again just day one.
NOTE CONF
Now I'm aware that there's a bit more stress around
studying these seven languages in seven weeks.
NOTE CONF
Things with the textbook.
It's just a clear set of things to understand.
NOTE CONF
You understand them all.
You're done, you know you no matter what question I
NOTE CONF
can give you, you'll get it right.
Um, but here we're looking at there's a lot of
NOTE CONF
information in each chapter and you're probably thinking.
Do I have to memorise all of this?
NOTE CONF
Do I have to know all of this?
Well, yes and no.
NOTE CONF
I wanna talk about that a little bit.
Conceptually, I want you to understand that the seven languages
NOTE CONF
in seven Weeks stuff or the the languages that we're
doing are treated as I think I said this at
NOTE CONF
the start.
I don't know why you're not showing up.
NOTE CONF
I was having to join um HD material, right.
I want people to be able to get really good
NOTE CONF
marks in this course credits and maybe even distinctions, even
if they don't do any of the seven languages stuff.
NOTE CONF
And this is for the students who are really interested
to stretch their legs.
NOTE CONF
Um and so that's totally acceptable then that we're talking
about something where maybe you're reading a whole day and
NOTE CONF
there's lots of little concepts and it's taken you quite
a while to get your head around it.
NOTE CONF
And then maybe one question pops up in an exam.
OK, cool.
NOTE CONF
That's how high distinction material works.
High distinction means above and beyond.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I don't just wanna leave it out there
for only people who are interested in the distinction stuff
NOTE CONF
because it's just so interesting even just chatting about these
languages and interesting and even just touching upon the topic.
NOTE CONF
And with a bit of luck, you might get a
question you know the answer to Well, why not?
NOTE CONF
Um, so I want you to look at it that
way.
NOTE CONF
I want you to look at it as Hey, look,
let's get as much as I can out of this
NOTE CONF
chapter Fingers crossed.
I happen to get a question on that.
NOTE CONF
Alright, that's me getting some bonus marks or No, I
love this course.
NOTE CONF
This is my favourite course of uni ever.
I'm gonna understand each of these seven languages chapters, the
NOTE CONF
day ones, just the day ones.
Um, And that way I'm covered.
NOTE CONF
And I'm the one who's gonna top the course right
closer.
NOTE CONF
Alright.
So it says closure is Is it Yoda?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Closure is Yoda, Um, and this is actually quite a
NOTE CONF
clever one.
Actually.
NOTE CONF
Most of his, um, analogies are clever.
Uh, or were they?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, uh, because closure is often written backwards to what
you expect.
NOTE CONF
And Yoda talks backwards to what you expect.
Uh, so it works nicely.
NOTE CONF
Closure is actually lisp.
Lisp is a much older language, but closure is a
NOTE CONF
modern lisp variant on the Java virtual machine, and it's
by far the most popular.
NOTE CONF
Well, is it by far the most popular lisp?
Probably it's probably the most used lip these days.
NOTE CONF
Um, the only other places people might be using lisp
are for teaching in universities, but closure is used commercially.
NOTE CONF
One of the reasons closure is popular is actually the
charisma of the benevolent dictator for life.
NOTE CONF
So as you're learning these multiple languages, you're probably coming
across the different, um, organisational structures that come with languages.
NOTE CONF
There is Richy, um, so the different organisational structures that
come with languages you've got, uh, languages like C and
NOTE CONF
C++, which are organised by open source ish committees of
people who make decisions.
NOTE CONF
Uh, HTML and CS.
S and JavaScript are also managed that way.
NOTE CONF
Those committees tend to have big, corporate, dominant corporate people
on those committees, but it's part of the committee.
NOTE CONF
The next model is run by a company, and the
company decides, and the company runs it.
NOTE CONF
That's the Java model, the C# model.
The what other languages can we think of model Uh,
NOTE CONF
And then finally, the benevolent dictator for Life model, which
is the guy who invented the language, Uh, just keeps
NOTE CONF
hanging on and controlling it, and he gets lots of
other people involved.
NOTE CONF
But ultimately, the decision is his.
And I say his because they're always his.
NOTE CONF
Um, probably just by fluke.
No, not by fluke.
NOTE CONF
But why aren't there any cheese?
Because mostly all these languages were done in the eighties
NOTE CONF
and the nineties and are still going now back when
it was even less, um, egalitarian than it is now.
NOTE CONF
So the benevolent dictator for life on Python is good,
Van Rossum, and as that's the main example, you'll know.
NOTE CONF
And in closure, it's Ricky and Rich.
He is a super good speaker on programming and programming
NOTE CONF
theory.
He's super good at enthusing people about better ways to
NOTE CONF
write programmes.
And so a lot of people have seen his talks
NOTE CONF
and gotten into closure because of that and certainly nothing.
And the fact that it's lisp lisp is the oldest
NOTE CONF
language around.
Um means that yes, he's not selling snake oil.
NOTE CONF
He's selling the real deal, OK, and you can do
very cool things in this and so he's really good
NOTE CONF
at selling the really cool things to a modern audience.
Whereas, um, old timers know all about lisp and love
NOTE CONF
lisp.
But there was a gap in the middle when OO
NOTE CONF
took over and everybody forgot about it.
OK, so list stands for list processor, and Li is
NOTE CONF
a language.
Enclosure is a language built around lists as the primary
NOTE CONF
data structure.
You might have noticed this by now that most of
NOTE CONF
these languages were introduced via their primary data structure.
Almost all of them end up with a dictionary and
NOTE CONF
an array or a list and maybe objects as well.
But the dictionary and the list which of those the
NOTE CONF
language is choosing tends to dominate the language's design.
Uh, list Enclosure goes with the list approach, but it's
NOTE CONF
more than just That's the dominant data structure.
The code is written in lists.
NOTE CONF
There's no source, there's just lists.
And when the list is a list of function calls,
NOTE CONF
then it's a programme.
And when the list is a list of numbers, then
NOTE CONF
it's some data.
Look at the features.
NOTE CONF
No, he's doing all this because it's built in Java.
You need to do a bit of stuff to get
NOTE CONF
JV MS involved.
But if we're scrolling into the rle, things are simple
NOTE CONF
enough so the people online will switch back.
I think I don't even know if I care enough
NOTE CONF
to switch to the people, but we'll do that.
So maybe I'll swap to having my computer on here
NOTE CONF
and then the visualizer on the other side, because people
at home can have the book with them if they
NOTE CONF
need it.
But they can't have my computer with them.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, so when I say everything's a list, I really
mean it lists open and close with parentheses.
NOTE CONF
So the parenthesis, which is so important to other languages
for parameter lists, is given over specifically to lists.
NOTE CONF
That is an empty list.
This is a list with a single thing in it.
NOTE CONF
OK, didn't like it.
The reason I didn't like it is that it wants
NOTE CONF
at this level where I'm where because I'm in the
rle.
NOTE CONF
It's expecting my list to be a piece of code.
Um, the list needs to have an uninterpreted function at
NOTE CONF
the front.
The first element of my list needs to be a
NOTE CONF
function, and then the remaining elements of the list are
the arguments to the function.
NOTE CONF
So again you can see where I've picked this for
this week, because until I've got the idea of an
NOTE CONF
uninterpreted function, I'm like, What the heck is that?
I just wrote, because in lisp, in closure, you really
NOTE CONF
don't pass arguments to functions.
You make a single list with a function at the
NOTE CONF
start, and then the arguments are after it, That's it.
And lists and closure when it sees a list with
NOTE CONF
an R function at the front goes ahead and evaluates
that function for you.
NOTE CONF
And I'm just gonna try something because yep, and in
closure, I can say, Hey, I'm giving you a list
NOTE CONF
and I don't want you to try and interpret it.
I don't want you to treat the first argument as
NOTE CONF
a function.
I put a little dash in front and I say,
NOTE CONF
No, no, this is just a list.
Just keep it as a list and look what it
NOTE CONF
did.
Kept it as a list.
NOTE CONF
Still just print line 123.
Nothing's evaluated.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I got code lists, which are parenthesis.
I got data lists, which is the dash or the
NOTE CONF
the What is it?
You better come up and then the the the list
NOTE CONF
of things and everything.
Here's a list.
NOTE CONF
Oh, Divide Did something funny?
That's right.
NOTE CONF
Oh, no.
Two thirds.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, let's do a plus because that might evaluate.
Here we go.
NOTE CONF
Um, everything is a list.
There's no separate operators.
NOTE CONF
There's no prefix infix postfix.
There's just lists with unin interpretative function stuff right now.
NOTE CONF
Theatre.
We just did 2.3 evaluated for five.
NOTE CONF
Oh, just two plus three.
Yeah, So that one will complain because I think it
NOTE CONF
will say two is not an interpreted function because if
I just give a parenthesis, it tries.
NOTE CONF
It'll always look at the first argument and say, That's
an I want that to be a function.
NOTE CONF
But if I do dash 23, it won't look at
them at all.
NOTE CONF
It'll just go.
Oh, you just want to give me the list.
NOTE CONF
23.
All right, I'll take it.
NOTE CONF
And so you get to choose exactly when evaluation happens,
use the parentheses to evaluate and the dash parenthesis to
NOTE CONF
not evaluate.
That's another really cool thing.
NOTE CONF
Complete control over evaluation.
And when it happens, uh, there's no precedents or associative
NOTE CONF
needed at all, because, um, if I want to, I
have to put the extra parenthesis in to make things
NOTE CONF
happen.
Um, in fact list the closure has a kind of
NOTE CONF
fake associative, which I love.
Let me show you the fake associative.
NOTE CONF
So that was me just putting in one plus two
plus three with the parenthesis to make it work.
NOTE CONF
But I can just put +123.
And it looks like I've done one plus two plus
NOTE CONF
three.
And I have ultimately, I've got six.
NOTE CONF
But what closure is really doing is it's when you
give an interpreted function and too many arguments, it just
NOTE CONF
does it to the first two and then takes the
result and does it to the next one and takes
NOTE CONF
the result and does it to the next one, which
is just like left associative but is different if you've
NOTE CONF
got side effects or something like that, a more basic
underlying concept, which is Oh, I had too many arguments.
NOTE CONF
So please just go again with the next argument gets
you left to sensitivity.
NOTE CONF
Hm.
It's exactly like a folder.
NOTE CONF
Yes, Uh, we're an object owned language, so we can
and look inside to see what we get.
NOTE CONF
Um, and you can see it's giving me that Java
lang types, uh, underneath its GDM.
NOTE CONF
And when you do divisions and mods, it doesn't try
and interpret them for you.
NOTE CONF
One of its tricks is that it sticks to infinite
precision arithmetic as long as it can.
NOTE CONF
So that's what I got when I did Div 23.
It says, No, I'm not gonna give you.
NOTE CONF
Let's well, let's do 32.
I'm not gonna give you 1.5.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna keep it at three.
On two.
NOTE CONF
Um, oops, look at that.
And now it's giving it back to me as three
NOTE CONF
N uh, which is obviously some special type of number.
So I'm gonna ask what type of number is it?
NOTE CONF
It's a big in, uh so begins for those who
aren't aware are normally the class that a library introduces
NOTE CONF
to keep infinite or higher precision on integers.
Um ah, This also shows you the reason that lisp
NOTE CONF
is abbreviated.
Sometimes there's lots of irritating silly parenthesis because this notation
NOTE CONF
here requires parenthesis everywhere.
So you end up with them bundling up the next
NOTE CONF
thing to notice though, is that you're programming with the
abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
Converting this to an abstract industry is super easy cos
every parenthesis is just a node in the tree, and
NOTE CONF
this style is called S expressions or L expressions.
One of the two.
NOTE CONF
There's a slight difference between the two.
I can't remember what, but this style of syntax is
NOTE CONF
a simple rule, completely universal.
Uh, utterly powerful.
NOTE CONF
Um, and if you can get your head around it,
it's the programming language designers, syntax of choice cos I
NOTE CONF
say you're basically programming with the A ST.
You're giving the comp the developer complete control of the
NOTE CONF
A ST Um they can interpret the parts of the
A ST as they want when they want in locks.
NOTE CONF
We discussed today how the interpretation of the tree is
bottom up.
NOTE CONF
Always not true in closure.
In closure, you stick a little dash in before a
NOTE CONF
list, and that bit doesn't get interpreted anymore.
Control over interpretation is down to the programmer, not the
NOTE CONF
compiler writer or the interpreter writer.
OK, the next example is just that strings are generally
NOTE CONF
operating the way we expect them to.
One thing I like about this um, Day one chapters
NOTE CONF
in the book is that they're not getting into the
deep concepts of each language, but they are touching on
NOTE CONF
something cool about the language.
Um, and so, yeah, so lists of strings of strings,
NOTE CONF
whatever.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
But again, we're seeing again that we have to print
line in front with the parentheses, cos that's this key
NOTE CONF
syntax This does he tell me whether it's S expressions
or L expressions here, I can't remember cos I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
do a scheme versus lisp, which we'll learn more well,
you'll hear a bit more about next week, right?
NOTE CONF
And famously.
By the way, Paul Graham, who's who knows who Paul
NOTE CONF
Graham is.
No, you've got no right wing tech bros in the
NOTE CONF
audience.
Paul Graham made a lot of money on the early
NOTE CONF
Internet, and then he's created Y Combinator, which was a
start up company in the in the west coast of
NOTE CONF
the US and made even more money from a bunch
of huge start-ups like I think, maybe Shopify and a
NOTE CONF
few others.
And now, just like every tech bro with too much
NOTE CONF
money, he's gone weirdo on his politics.
Um, but he wrote his his first thing was written
NOTE CONF
lisp and famously wrote this big article about how lisp
was his competitive advantage.
NOTE CONF
Um, so there's another thing here.
Uh, alright.
NOTE CONF
Just showing that you can have a character.
The slash notation allows you to write a character instead
NOTE CONF
of a string instead of using.
You don't use single inverted commas in closure.
NOTE CONF
You use the backslash, uh, to say the character.
He was just pointing out the different things the string
NOTE CONF
function can do.
Um, And interestingly, down here, if you pass the string
NOTE CONF
function more than one argument, it just prints them all
out one after the other.
NOTE CONF
So that's slightly different to what plus does when you
give it more than one argument.
NOTE CONF
Uh, it's OK.
All functions allow to functions of car.
NOTE CONF
All prep prepared to take more than one argument because
they're just expecting a freeform list of arguments right now.
NOTE CONF
This is great, but not enough.
So the language is built around lists, but closure also
NOTE CONF
adds vectors, sets functions, and these symbols are back.
Do you remember symbols from ruby love me symbol symbols
NOTE CONF
back.
So when does he first introduce the symbols so he
NOTE CONF
can be clear?
about them.
NOTE CONF
I don't think he's great about me.
I think he just uses them all right.
NOTE CONF
Anyway, symbols are back.
Well, this is where they started.
NOTE CONF
So again, a symbol, a reminder.
A symbol is an identifier with a colon in front,
NOTE CONF
and it's representing something unique but undefined, by which I
mean R.
NOTE CONF
Two D two is always different from C.
Three.
NOTE CONF
PO.
It's always the same as R two, D two, but
NOTE CONF
I don't know what it is in reality.
Inside the compiler, you know, it'll just say I found
NOTE CONF
a symbol.
This one's symbol is attached to the number one.
NOTE CONF
Now the next symbol gets attached to the number two
and that keeps them moving along just fine.
NOTE CONF
The reason symbols are so good and the way Ruby
uses them and also the way li uh, clo uses
NOTE CONF
them is they're the perfect placeholders for a key in
a dictionary.
NOTE CONF
If you've done much programming with dictionaries, you're often just
using a string as the key.
NOTE CONF
And all you really want is to say this key
is, you know, name and this key is address.
NOTE CONF
Wouldn't it be nicer to be able to say you
don't have to hold the whole string name and the
NOTE CONF
whole string address.
Just hold any old number.
NOTE CONF
I'm calling it name.
Hold any old number.
NOTE CONF
I'm calling it address and just make sure you keep
them separate.
NOTE CONF
That's what symbols that you do.
You put colon name, colon address and every time you
NOTE CONF
want to use them, you use name and address, so
they still have the meaning.
NOTE CONF
But internally, the compiler goes cool.
I don't have to keep a big, long string.
NOTE CONF
I can just keep the shortest possible thing I can.
That makes this work, which is a unsigned check.
NOTE CONF
So they often end up replacing strings because that's the
place they exist.
NOTE CONF
And they're better than strings.
And those of you in Java who constantly try to
NOTE CONF
compare strings and then get the wrong answer because strings
you need to compare with the DOT equals operator.
NOTE CONF
Well, understand why it can be better.
OK, so let's talk about vectors a little bit, right?
NOTE CONF
So he he talks about the lists and the interpreting
of them.
NOTE CONF
He talks about lists having functions first and last.
Um, he talks about cons, which have we talked about
NOTE CONF
cons yet all right.
Should we talk about cons?
NOTE CONF
Let's try cons.
Cons is a concept that appears in multiple places.
NOTE CONF
So it's worth talking about.
Um I'm just gonna try something.
NOTE CONF
No, he doesn't like cons on that 10, because the
second one's got to be a list lips from when?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, there we go.
OK, so how how's what's the best way to explain
NOTE CONF
this?
What, did Karen go to work?
NOTE CONF
Ah, K.
And could have Don't work.
NOTE CONF
Oh, sorry.
I got sidetracked there a little bit.
NOTE CONF
When you are working entirely with lists, everything is list.
Your language is lists, then exactly how lists get created
NOTE CONF
and uncreated and all that is very important.
Uh, way back in the olden days, you and I
NOTE CONF
are used to building lists by just writing them out.
Maybe we're used to building a list by appending to
NOTE CONF
it.
Maybe you get a list and you call it the
NOTE CONF
list, and you call it dot append method.
And then you gotta think to yourself whether it depends
NOTE CONF
at the start or the end.
Um, but when performance matters, and then you should always
NOTE CONF
append to the left hand side of a list.
You know why.
NOTE CONF
If you've done link lists cos that's a order one
operation whereas adding to the end of a link list
NOTE CONF
is an order, an operation.
So the standard way to build lists like the very
NOTE CONF
smallest set of things you can do for building a
list is to be able to do an empty list
NOTE CONF
and then add an element to the front of it.
I come two cons one Oops.
NOTE CONF
OK, And the argument that the function that does that
is cons, probably for constructor.
NOTE CONF
But now we will just think of it as cons.
This is an example of list going backwards or closure
NOTE CONF
going backwards to create the list.
20, no, this is forwards 21, cons.
NOTE CONF
Two cons, one.
but the first thing that occurred in this was the
NOTE CONF
cons one.
And then the second thing that occurred was the cons
NOTE CONF
two.
So that's why I end up reading backwards, because I've
NOTE CONF
got to read from the innermost outwards to understand the
order of operations.
NOTE CONF
So cons is the simplest way to build up a
list.
NOTE CONF
And then in old school lists, car and kuda are
how you pull apart a list, but in, um in
NOTE CONF
in closure, he's used the better names first and last.
Is it first and last first and rest first and
NOTE CONF
rest.
Yeah, first again, The only efficient way to pull apart
NOTE CONF
a list is one at a time taking the head
off and so you can take the head off to
NOTE CONF
get back the head.
Or you can take the head off to get back
NOTE CONF
the rest.
And those are the operations available on this.
NOTE CONF
So cons empty list.
First and last, that's enough for doing lists, but of
NOTE CONF
course, there'll be more built in.
But any language that does really good support for lists,
NOTE CONF
we use those same concepts.
And so knowing cons and most languages, we use the
NOTE CONF
the the Value nil for an empty list or something
like that.
NOTE CONF
So it's K nil.
First, LA, uh, first rest or K nil Ka ka
NOTE CONF
and K and Kuta are just first and rest in
some old school language car being car and ka being
NOTE CONF
ka.
Um, but you don't ask often for the last element
NOTE CONF
of the list.
You just tend not to process them that way, although
NOTE CONF
I bet there's a last in there if I wanted
it.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, it's there.
OK, so vectors.
NOTE CONF
What's the difference with a vector?
It's just, um I right, so with lists, and this
NOTE CONF
is one of the things added in with closure.
I think that doesn't exist in Li.
NOTE CONF
We're so used to wanting to access things, not just
from the start to the end, especially when we're trying
NOTE CONF
to write fast code.
Uh, it's nice to have some data structure that internally
NOTE CONF
is optimised so that if I ask for the fifth
element, it can go there quickly, not have to go
NOTE CONF
there slowly.
And so that's what vectors are, and they use square
NOTE CONF
brackets instead.
Um, and closure gives you this at the syntax level,
NOTE CONF
right?
So you write almost all your closure with parentheses, but
NOTE CONF
you want a vector.
You can just jam it in there with square brackets.
NOTE CONF
Um, also keep noting that all these things just use
spaces in between.
NOTE CONF
We don't have to worry about the commas in between.
Everything, uh, it's been nice.
NOTE CONF
And yeah, so there's nth.
There's an nth function built in, but again, everything is
NOTE CONF
just an uninterpreted function and its arguments.
There's no square bracket notation for getting into an array.
NOTE CONF
You just have to call the nth function past the
array and at the start of the vector and the
NOTE CONF
and the index you want as the second one.
It's a minimal notation.
NOTE CONF
Sets are introduced as well, and sets just free you
from having to worry about the ordering of things.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, it uses curly braces with a hash in
front.
NOTE CONF
I think it might have been out of Where did
he put the hash in front?
NOTE CONF
I don't know.
Curly braces aren't used for anything else at the moment.
NOTE CONF
Uh, maybe it's got something to do with Java Interop,
who knows, But again, just a different type of, um,
NOTE CONF
parenthesis.
And you're in a totally different type of data structure.
NOTE CONF
But it's really nice.
And finally maps.
NOTE CONF
Oh, there you go.
He's using just parentheses for maps by themselves.
NOTE CONF
Um, a map.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
This is where things get a bit funny.
I think, um, with a map, use the normal, uh,
NOTE CONF
braces, and then you again, you just line up all
the arguments one after the other with spaces.
NOTE CONF
But in fact, chewy and wookie are the ones attached
key value.
NOTE CONF
Leah and human key value are the ones that are
attached.
NOTE CONF
Um, and if you only put three, you get a
problem because you got a key value and a key
NOTE CONF
No value.
Um, And because that does get a bit confusing the
NOTE CONF
parenthesis, the the commas are allowed just to make it
a bit easier for you to read.
NOTE CONF
Ah, sorry.
Here we go.
NOTE CONF
The word proceeded with Colin is a keyword like symbols
in Ruby or Adams in pro, where I learn, um,
NOTE CONF
closure has two types, keywords and symbols.
Keywords point to something else, and keywords point to themselves.
NOTE CONF
OK, that's a funny idea.
Oh, OK, so a keyword.
NOTE CONF
So we were calling them symbols.
But here they're not symbols.
NOTE CONF
Symbols are like the built in values like true and
false.
NOTE CONF
And then they introduced a new word for those called
keyword.
NOTE CONF
But they operate just like the symbols do.
There we go, and we're defining maps.
NOTE CONF
OK, how do you define your own function?
Well, exactly the same way you do everything else.
NOTE CONF
There's a special function called deafen, and you give it
all of its arguments.
NOTE CONF
And its first argument is the name of the function.
The second argument is the vector of arguments, and then
NOTE CONF
the third argument is the expression that is the body
of the function.
NOTE CONF
So every function is just one expression, but that expression
can be as complicated as you want.
NOTE CONF
Um, so this is clearly an expression based language.
And there clearly has to be something that's not in
NOTE CONF
the first, uh, day.
If we wanted to write multi line functions, what would
NOTE CONF
they look like?
Uh, they're they're multi line, but they're single expression.
NOTE CONF
So again, it's just gonna be a guess.
What?
NOTE CONF
It's gonna be another parenthesis and another function.
And the function is just gonna have multiple arguments.
NOTE CONF
And probably each argument is one of the statements that's
being executed.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we'll finish up by talking.
Ah, so anonymous functions exist, So he's defining.
NOTE CONF
Uh, de is how you make a variable, by the
way.
NOTE CONF
So this makes a variable people that is storing this
vector.
NOTE CONF
Uh, there's a function called count and there's a map.
So that's using the first class function count across the
NOTE CONF
people.
Where is he defining his?
NOTE CONF
Uh, yeah, the map we've seen before.
There's a new function being defined definite twice count takes
NOTE CONF
a single argument, works out its count, times it by
two.
NOTE CONF
Then you can run twice.
Count across people.
NOTE CONF
Where's the anonymous function?
With the short form?
NOTE CONF
Hash defines an anonymous function with percent bound to each
item in the sequence.
NOTE CONF
OK, so to do this before.
So when we were mapping up here, the function had
NOTE CONF
to have a name down here.
I wanna M instead of having to name that function
NOTE CONF
and put it over here, I'd like to just be
able to put it directly in line.
NOTE CONF
And so there's a nice syntax for writing functions directly
in line.
NOTE CONF
Uh, it's a hash parenthesis.
And then that will whatever's inside the parenthesis is treated
NOTE CONF
as the body of the function and percent symbol is
treated as the argument to the function.
NOTE CONF
OK, go.
That's a little bit too pearly for me.
NOTE CONF
Um, but yeah, he talks to, uh, Bruce, uh, Richard,
about why he created it.
NOTE CONF
And mostly he says, because I wanted a language like
this and one didn't exist.
NOTE CONF
Well, lisp obviously existed, but, um, he wanted one on
the JDM and his focuses on abstractions in particular, the
NOTE CONF
data abstractions, and I don't know if you can see
it at this point, but one thing lisp or closure
NOTE CONF
gives you almost for free is meta programming if you've
ever used the reflection API in Java to make Java
NOTE CONF
code?
Or do what we did with the A ST generator,
NOTE CONF
where we just built up a big string and printed
it to a file in a language like closure that
NOTE CONF
can be done much more, principally using the same tools
as the language you end up instead of generating a
NOTE CONF
string that then gets printed out into a dot Java
file and acts as our class, you end up building
NOTE CONF
up another list.
That is the computation that you're trying to define.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so meta programming is very cool, and that's a
big one on the abstractions.
NOTE CONF
Um, he doesn't love his box numbers.
That's fine.
NOTE CONF
And, he points out, Flight casts us as a Web
service.
NOTE CONF
Um, languages with good concurrency and good abstractions seem to
be especially good for operating over the Web, where everything
NOTE CONF
is a unreliable stream of data across a rest.
Service and closure is one of those Why did it
NOTE CONF
kick off?
Well, I said, because he's charismatic.
NOTE CONF
But he says, because there just wasn't enough of the
practical tools built in, he's suggesting that the small, syntactic
NOTE CONF
changes he made, like calling out vectors and a few
other things.
NOTE CONF
There's a few other things he's done along the way
are the things that just got it over the line
NOTE CONF
from being a esoteric, um, theoretical tool to something that
people are happy to use practically OK, And Key actually
NOTE CONF
points out that in a lot of places, this introducing
of these extra syntax is actually just to get rid
NOTE CONF
of the parenthesis, um, to save you from them in
a few places where it's easy to save you from
NOTE CONF
them.
Um, and we haven't gotten to some big examples here,
NOTE CONF
but for a programmer not used to this in this
style of programming, the reading backwards thing does take a
NOTE CONF
bit of getting used to, um and I think so.
I mean, conceptually, think of yourself.
NOTE CONF
I mean, you know how you can acclimatise to something,
and if you move from, if we move from here
NOTE CONF
to Hobart after a few years, you probably would be
acclimatised to the weather, and instead of wearing short sleeves
NOTE CONF
when it's, um, 22 degrees, you'd be wearing short sleeves
when it was 12 degrees.
NOTE CONF
Um, but if you move to Antarctica, you can't acclimatise.
You won't be wearing short sleeves at minus 22 degrees
NOTE CONF
with funny features like this.
Some of them are on the wrong side of the
NOTE CONF
acclimatisation limit.
When you've only got this syntax, I think it's like
NOTE CONF
Antarctica.
It's just a bit too much for a human to
NOTE CONF
acclimatise to.
And what Richard's suggesting is he's given just enough syntactic
NOTE CONF
tricks to get you to Hobart so that, yes, it's
still in acclimatisation phase.
NOTE CONF
But, um, it's doable.
And once you get there, it feels natural, as opposed
NOTE CONF
to always being freezing cold, which is what the list
still feels like to me.
NOTE CONF
After a long, long time of programming with all kinds
of things and backwards and blah, blah, blah alrighty, that
NOTE CONF
might do us for today.
Are there any other questions?
NOTE CONF
Let me see if I've got any that pop through
online.
NOTE CONF
Uh, yes, um, so someone There's another comment about the
instructions for zipping, but again, a reiteration.
NOTE CONF
I mean, I'll read this one properly, Um, but just
a reiteration that Yes, I've been through all the explanations,
NOTE CONF
and I'm very comfortable that the instructions were clear.
Correct?
NOTE CONF
And that it's a skill.
You should have to follow those instructions.
NOTE CONF
Um, but this person might not be saying that, but
a lot of people have been saying I shouldn't have
NOTE CONF
had to follow those instructions.
This other thing was just as obvious.
NOTE CONF
No, no, You can't submit programmes in the wrong form
and expect them to operate in the right way.
NOTE CONF
Um, so we're gonna learn how to do the zipping.
I mean, anybody, I'll read that properly offline and answer
NOTE CONF
it if I have to.
Yeah, OK.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Thanks, everybody.
NOTE CONF
Alright.
So there are people hanging around.
NOTE CONF
What are we hanging around for?
Or No.
NOTE CONF
Everyone's good to go.
There are some people.
NOTE CONF
I said, come see me after the lecture.
So those people should come down and see me.
NOTE CONF
Now I'll mute everything